For decades, Hollywood has derived blockbuster
drama from natural disasters both real and
imagined.
From the all-star disaster movie classics
of the '70s through the effects-driven spectacles
of more recent decades, there's nothing quite
like the thrill of watching things go horribly
awry from the comfort of your couch or local
cineplex.
In the interest of saving you some time — since,
as these films remind us, the clock is indeed
ticking for us all — here's a look at some
disaster films that simply can't be missed.
The Poseidon Adventure
2006's Poseidon was a regrettable remake of
1972's The Poseidon Adventure and should be
ignored at all costs.
However, the original, about a group of luxury
liner passengers trapped in an upside-down
vessel that's slowly but surely sinking, is
well worth wading through.
Anchored by Gene Hackman and Shelley Winters,
the film presents a gripping look at what
might happen to a group of well-off vacationers
when a tidal wave capsizes their ship and
leaves them scrambling for escape from a watery
grave.
Special effects have obviously evolved since
then, but the patient pace and fully realized
characters are increasingly rare among the
modern crop of blockbuster action movies.
"I started to believe in your promises, that
we had a chance."
The Towering Inferno
Starring Paul Newman, Steve McQueen, Faye
Dunaway, and Fred Astaire, The Towering Inferno
was star-studded to say the least.
The film centers on the blazing drama that
spreads after the world's tallest building
— the Glass Tower — goes up in flames
after an electrical circuit goes haywire during
the Tower's dedication ceremony.
The blaze leaves entire families trapped dozens
of stories above the ground.
And beneath the obvious appeal of The Towering
Inferno's survival story is a cutting commentary
on corporate greed and the true cost of the
bottom line.
Alive
Inspired by a real-life Uruguayan rugby team
who were stranded in the snow-capped Andes
mountains after their small plane crashed,
Alive is a chillingly raw depiction of the
group's efforts to survive the accident — and
the cruel climate where they were stranded.
Based on Piers Paul Read's written account,
the movie spares no bitter details about what
these athletes had to do to crawl through
each day until rescue arrived.
From the drawn-out suffering of gangrene and
frostbite to their desperate decision to nourish
themselves on the flesh of the fallen, the
fact that it's based on a true story makes
the cinematic experience that much more unsettling.
Outbreak
At a time when the spread of communicable
diseases was a growing social concern, thanks
in large part to the uncertainty surrounding
AIDS, Wolfgang Petersen's Outbreak capitalized
on those fears spectacularly.
"Dammit, Sam I wanna save these people same
as you."
Thanks to its deadly virus going airborne
and remaining undetectable until symptoms
started presenting in infected patients, Outbreak
made everyone a potential threat — and showcased
the societal collapse and militaristic governmental
oppression that could so easily unfold in
the wake of such a threat.
It wasn't the first or last film to explore
such a viral phenomenon, but the climate of
the film's release, combined with the breadth
of its fictional disease's impact, made it
a must-see.
Daylight
The brawny action prowess of Sylvester Stallone
in his prime in Rob Cohen's Daylight offered
a spectacular foundation for Sly the Savior
at his best.
Stallone starred as a former EMS medic who
puts himself in harm's way to help those who
became trapped in New York's Holland Tunnel
after a group of diamond thieves crash into
a chemical waste truck, triggering an explosion.
It all adds up to an action-packed race against
time — and the Hudson River — set in an
eerie darkness.
Twister
This pic might be best remembered for its
giant storms and special effects, but Twister's
superior acting and emotional subplots are
what made the movie such a standout.
Sure, the dialogue can get a little silly
…
"Cow!"
"I gotta go, Julia, we got cows!"
But for the most part, Twister does a terrific
job of balancing human drama — like a dissolving
marriage and a character's childhood trauma
— against the effects-driven chaos audiences
demand from a film about tornado chasers.
It's still very easy to be swept up in, even
decades later.
Dante's Peak
Audiences had their pick of magma-movies in
1997, with Dante's Peak and Volcano both erupting
in quick succession at theaters.
But whereas Volcano threatened the entire
metropolitan area of Los Angeles, Dante's
Peak benefited from a narrower focus, zooming
in on a small town and letting viewers get
to know and care about its characters.
Additionally, Peak's hero relied on his scientific
expertise, rather than sheer bravado.
And while Volcano leans heavily on ordinary
action movie conventions to carry the plot
along, Dante's Peak offers some upsettingly
creative scenes of chaos that still hold up
even now.
Deep Impact
Mimi Leder's Deep Impact was miles above Michael
Bay's Armageddon.
Rather than relying on a ridiculous action
thriller fantasy of sending cowboy oil drillers
into space — y'know, instead of actual astronauts
— Deep Impact actually relied on the expertise
of scientists, and it shows.
More importantly, the movie wasn't just about
showcasing the heroism of a few astronauts,
but focused on the scattered impact and personal
sacrifices that could result from impending
doom in various parts of the world.
There are still some efforts to thwart the
rock from colliding with Earth, of course,
but the most memorable moments are grounded
in the smaller-scale drama that holds the
sci-fi action together.
The Wave
Plenty of disaster movies have used avalanches
or tsunamis to fuel the action, but Roar Uthaug's
The Wave stands out due to its stunning cinematography
and its main characters' intensely affecting
arc.
Nothing about the movie is particularly groundbreaking,
but its obedience to formula is easy to forgive
thanks to Uthaug's visual style and a screenplay
that's driven as much by its relatable characters
as it is by the titular catastrophe.
The Impossible
The Indian Ocean tsunami of 2004 cost hundreds
of thousands of human lives and leveled coastlines
in over a dozen countries.
Any movie that dared to dramatize this real-life
disaster would have to deal with the story
sensitively — and J.A. Bayona's The Impossible
did just that.
The film waded through the endless misery
of the story to find a glimmering, albeit
somewhat controversial, piece of hope in the
Belon family, who defied the odds and managed
to survive the storm.
As with all the best disaster movies, the
viewing experience can be grueling, but it
pays inspiring dividends.
And as a bonus?
Check out the young Spider-Man!
*screaming*
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!